i won again dad uh uh emmy coach see you
gentlemen have found my latest cheat the
human centerpied you see tom is getting
old and needs extra protection i'll then
apply anti-aging organic eye black made
from the ashes of jimmy garoppolo's
contract extension gisele was wrong one
day i will throw and catch the ball
light reps for the normal players
meditation for tom's cult okay thanks
here's my special mind power
the patriots do not rebuild we reload
um coach are we cool no oh hi coach have
you met our terrible backup yet hello
i'm thomas
thank goodness for the tuck rule one
more and i'll have just as many as the
steelers fun teams in the afc i will
restore order to the universe calm down
phil
in my experience giving him back the
ball is bad geez we get it oh hey look i
got us over time overtime rules tom gets
to punch first if he misses patrick gets
the punch wait i might not get to play
great competitor hell of a game
hallelujah i don't even know who you are
jared's a system quarterback just like
you not true
you shouldn't have gone for my head no
rubbing the bathroom
thanos didn't go far enough i collected
all six coach we can finally retire now
you gotta fill this one up we deserve
this you think biggest wrong i don't
need coach it'll always be pick 199.
i lied to hulu i'll do it i'll move i
don't think about you as much as you
think i do oh i had three almonds last
night what happened uh-oh your mom and
dad i'm not enjoying camp anymore pick
me up we have to use our legs still fair
bucks are sus yeah i'm suss successful
under stress that's fine i'm pretty sure
it's still fourth down what's up oh wait
is rogers already being the competitive
bully let's race winner gets control of
the mountain loser never comes back what
no let's just wait till next year man
next year where nice try but i upgraded
my weapon i could actually win take that
dad i mean belichick i mean aryan what
up man want to see me make something out
of nothing
that child is going to die no more new
people hey guys have you seen all this
snow it's like buffalo in the summer
i'm gonna try to beat you wow the
disrespect at last my final four and now
i'm the perfect qb now kneel before the
ghost every dumb little completion
after killing me what did you plan on
doing next what the hell you're 43 years
old you best start believing in good
stories mr rogers you're in one
see it goes right through me and that's
the result of a healthy pliable life
there once was a team twas lost at sea
to there came a man named tom brady
ditched winston they began to win throw
less picks tom throw and you're sure
young people like this seashell is hot
now better not be messing with me i do
not want to let go if i win without
belichick i'll be free of the curse of
the system qb
oh god did i kill patrick mahomes i
could probably get away with this this
is my legacy i'm only 25. you know
there's 52 other players on the team
right and king b and the goats these
dudes are like hottest bro i saw you in
college you're really good at football
thank you so you agree
you think you're really good at football
i found this bulletin board material i
think the rookies made it
look everyone i'm sorry if my greatness
infuriates you but i dare you to come at
me thank you but we all brought our own
weird food this thing honestly drives
itself at this point
the patriot rt we need to eat the week
already we just crashed
i decide where gronk goes always boy the
jets were tough i don't know how we did
it but yo if you enter someone's selfie
does it become an uh